es un descubrimiento que hace temblar a
los gobiernos de todo el mundo el mes
pasado periodistas obtuvieron pruebas de
que se encontraron documentos
clasificados de alto secreto algunos de
ellos relacionados con naciones
extranjeras en la residencia de donald
trump en florida ahora hay más según el
washington post los agentes del fbi que
registraron mar al lago encontraron un
documento que escribía la defensa
militar de un gobierno extranjero
incluyendo su capacidad nuclear el país
no fue nombrado pero el descubrimiento
supera ya las preocupaciones entre los
funcionarios de inteligencia sobre el
material clasificado que fue llevado a
la residencia privada
otros documentos recuperados describen
operaciones estadounidenses tan secretas
que muchos funcionarios de seguridad
nacional no las conocen estos documentos
altamente clasificados se guardan
siempre bajo llave casi siempre en una
instalación de información segura y con
un oficial de control designado pero
estos documentos se guardaron en mar a
lago con un nivel de seguridad
durante 18 meses después de que trump
dejara la casa blanca los investigadores
creen que había más de 300 documentos
clasificados en la propiedad el
expresidente ha negado haber actuado mal
el pasado fin de semana hizo su primera
aparición pública desde la redada del
fbi en su casa de florida calificándola
de parodia
la vergonzosa redada y allanamiento de
mi casa mar al lago fue una parodia de
la justicia que se burló de las leyes
tradiciones y principios de eeuu ante el
mundo entero el mundo entero estaba
mirando y está conmocionado orden ayer
world in the world watch en under sad el
lunes un juez federal concedió la
solicitud de trump de un experto
especial que se encargará de revisar los
documentos incautados en mara lago la
decisión probablemente retrasará la
investigación del departamento de
justicia sobre los documentos